hello friends we are talking today about
hidden motives in everyday life
Robin Hansen is the author of the
elephant in the brain this book is an
evolutionary look at why we do the
things we do what are the reasons that
our brain is encouraging us to perform
particular actions and how are we
deceived by the monkey inside of our own
mind if you've never doubled in the
world of evolutionary psychology before
this is a fantastic introduction to it
and it I found it super interesting we
break down why competition is such an
important driving factor for humans how
collectively established rules and norms
came about in hunter-gatherer societies
and why they're important we also talk
about the dark side of those rules and
norms about lying and cheating and how
evolutionarily it's a very effective way
to move forward we look at the laughter
from an evolutionary perspective
conversations body language gossip and
why there is a justification for gossip
actually being useful in hunter-gatherer
societies and in the modern day how
consumer behavior is influenced by
hidden motives health care altruism and
being charitable and an awful lot more
what's super interesting and I think
very liberating about this discussion is
the fact that it reminds us just how at
the mercy of our primitive brains we
really are now our environment has
progressed an awful lot over the last
5000 years but our brains haven't
changed all that much and it's nice and
important to be reminded of the fact
that were basically just hairless apes
that have managed to harness a little
bit of electricity so let's find the
elephant in our brains
[Music]
Robin Hanson welcome to modern wisdom
how are you today I'm very happy to be
here
so we're going to talk about interesting
stuff currently we are going to talk
about interesting stuff yeah we're gonna
blow some minds today I think so you are
an associate professor of economics at
George Mason University and a research
associate at the future of humanity
Institute of Oxford amongst other titles
I am indeed so reading your website the
bio is a lot like being hosed down with
a bit of a pressure washer you've got
over three thousand eight hundred and
ninety citations and have been published
nearly a hundred times across a very
very wide range of fields what why is
your work so eclectic why is it so
varied
well most academics basically look for a
secure place a place where they are an
authority and where they can contribute
and where they've been rewarded and then
they stay there mmm-hmm and I've been
much more of a wanderer looking for the
most interesting topics and especially
looking for anything more interesting
than what I've been working on lately so
it's in the past I held myself to the
standard of if I wasn't going to go into
a new area I should produce a
publication there that would be
published by the experts in that area
and that would acknowledge that I had
made a contribution and that would
justify the fact that I had distracted
myself from other things and done
something in that area yeah I get that
completely so that's a bit of signaling
I suppose straight away which is what
we're gonna we're gonna get stuck into
in a little bit so your book elephant in
the brain hidden motives in everyday
life it came out at the start of the
year can you tell us why you wrote this
book so this is the answer to a puzzle
that's been bothering me all my life
okay and so I've been noticing that in
many areas there's just a lot of things
that don't make sense a lot of things
that are strange and that's been bugging
me for a long time why are all these
strange things they're like why doesn't
the world make
and I decided well this was an answer to
a lot of puzzles a lot of reasons why
things don't make sense is that we've
been just making the wrong assumption
likey wrong assumption about motives in
most areas people have a standard motive
they'll tell you about why they do it
and we usually just take them at their
word and think about the details and I
realize that in an awful lot of areas
they're just wrong about their basic
motives the the most fundamental thing
they're saying about why they're doing
it is in an important sense wrong do you
think that's consciously wrong or a
combination of deceptive and unconscious
motivations it varies it's cop that part
is complicated because we each vary in
ourselves and and what's important to us
etc so each one of us tends to have
something in our lives that we consider
the most sacred and important and in
that area we insist on idealism about
our mothers we insist so if you're a
researcher say and that's the thing
that's your sacred thing then you are
really it's really important to you that
you see your motive in research as high
and important you have to justify your
respect for that and making it so
central to you and then in most other
areas of your life you're more willing
to accept lower motives because those
aren't central to your identity even if
people might say they do things for some
high motive you're willing to admit well
yeah people say that but they don't mean
it quite as much as they say and I'm
willing to admit that I aren't you don't
really quite so focused on that because
that's less the center of your life I
get that I get that totally so let's ask
the the main question that everyone
wants to know what is the elephant in
the brain the elephant in the brain is a
metaphor analogous to the elephant in
the room so the elephant in the room is
this thing we all know is there but we
don't want to talk about so we step
around it and we pretend it's not there
and the elephant and your brain is the
thing that you all kind of know is there
in your brain that you don't want to
talk about and it's the motives that you
have that you don't like to admit to
most of which are more selfish than
you'd like to admit okay
so there's a collect quote about your
book which I absolutely love
and it says everything from higher
education to belief in God is best
understood through the prism of an
elaborate mating ritual predicated on
innumerable intersecting status
competitions are we just essentially
hairless monkeys it's not is that the
long and short of it welljust is too
strong just would say there's nothing
more yeah we are certainly something
more yeah but we do exaggerate how
different we are certainly we are much
more like other monkeys and other
primates than we'd like to admit we
often pretend as if humans are just this
whole separate set of creatures for whom
the usual animal rules just don't apply
and that's definitely not true but we
are different in many important ways and
we are not just the same as all the
other animals I get that I get that
totally so have you got some examples of
similarities between ourselves and
monkeys that might strike home to some
of the listeners well I don't study
monkeys per se myself but a common
observation about primates and many
other kinds of monkeys is that they
spend a lot of time grooming they sit
and pick at each other's back
taking out bugs and dirt and that's just
a thing lots of primates do and we don't
do so much of that directly but we
indirectly groom by talking well we are
accomplishing a similar thing and a
little larger groups by just hanging
around with each other and talking and
basically saying I'm willing to spend
time with you I'm willing to focus my
attention on you and do these modest
things that would seem to be in your
interest to help you mainly just to show
you that I'm with you and and I support
you mm-hmm so what's the what's the
justification for that or what's the
reasoning behind that that it comes
comes through to us as humans now you
can see why you would do that as a
monkey but what's the motivation for us
as humans in the woman so if humans were
looking at monkeys picking each other
you know each other's fur we'd say we're
helping cleaning their fur but in fact
they spend a lot more time doing that
they need to keep you two
clean so it seems to be more of a
political activity they're doing it to
show their alliance with each other and
so they actually do more of it when
there are larger groups when they have
more people they need to reassure of
their alliance with so humans are also
in large groups and we also need to show
each other that we are loyal and that we
are with them in various groups but we
don't like to say that out loud
indirectly and so we do all these things
with each other whose indirect purpose
is to reassure each other that we're
together and we like each other and
we're loyal to each other but we need to
make up other excuses for what we're
actually doing yes so we talk we talk
and we converse and we talk as if we
cared that much about the sporting team
or the latest news news story etc our
delight is gossip and we just have to
have all these other reasons that we say
for what we're doing because we aren't
as comfortable directly saying I'm just
doing this to show that you and I are
still an item I get that I get that so
I'm right in thinking that monkeys or
primates they spend a disproportionate
amount of time on the more higher social
status primates within the group when
they're doing that rest of course
absolutely and it's not that that would
be reflected I suppose with people
laughing at the boss's joke right or so
we definitely select who we spend the
time with and who we pay attention to
according to social status and prestige
we're much more interested in gaining
the attention of and showing our
allegiance to people who are higher
status mm-hmm yeah I totally get that so
why is competition such an important
driving factor for humans or fur for
animals overall well the standard story
which is right is that animals are in a
fierce competition in the long run
evolution is this you know process that
never ends whereby in each generation
some people have more descendants than
others and whatever features produce
having more descendants are rewarded and
emphasized and over many many
generations those are the features we
all have we are all packed full of the
features that tend to promote having
more descendents yep and competition is
one of those features
so sending and receiving of our signals
as a potential partner and survival
these are all key drivers right now when
people think about competition they
often think about it in contrast
cooperation as if yes the opposites and
of course in a more direct sense we are
cooperating most of the time but we are
cooperating as a strategy to compete
that is if you and I are cooperating
with each other that then if it's you
and I relative to all the other people
out there who might not be cooperating
quite as much as we are yes and so the
strict competition induces cooperation
as a strategy to win the competition
so you bond together in small groups
it's still to take the top spot but if
you need to if you need to buddy up with
a number of other animals you can do it
and you do need to and typically you
need to get into relatively large groups
so humans have pioneered very large
social groups very large complicated
social groups that other primates
certainly I didn't have and that's one
of our triumphs is that we are able to
cooperate at much larger scales than
other primates what's the what's the
comparison there in terms of numbers
well Millions yep you know so most
primates might cooperate in a group of
you know eight to ten or something and
humans originally forgers would
cooperate in groups of 20 to 50 in some
local local neighbors up 250 but today
if we cooperated in groups of many
millions yep and that's just way out of
the scale of what other primates can
manage yeah so was that one of the key
drivers of human progression was the
fact that we were able to create these
complex social structures and sustain
them as well so it wasn't like you just
put everyone in a in a group and then
after a couple of weeks everyone just
ripped each other shreds well certainly
our being able to manage large groups is
an important part of our evolution and
the way we manage them is important to
understanding what we
and how we interact so clearly we have
built on larger and larger groups over
time and we've added more and more
structure to how we do that but you can
get lost in all that if you don't go
back to the very first smallest groups
and ask how did we at least manage those
and so these small groups of 20 to 50
people we were able to have larger
groups than most other primates because
we had social norms so social norms are
rules about what you're supposed to do
or not supposed to do and the rules that
other people enforce third parties
enforce so the key idea is if I see you
breaking your rule I'm supposed to tell
other people and then we're supposed to
talk about what to do about your
breaking the rule and so we will then
coordinate to respond now we will
respond first in small ways if we can
get you to stop in the small way but we
will have a set of escalations available
to us so ends in killing you off if
necessary because that's that's always
in the background as an available option
but we have these social norms so that's
a key distinction between us and other
animals other animals have typical
behaviors and you can call those norms
if you like but that's not the same as
the norm in humans where you're supposed
to enforce the Normans so non enforcing
enormous is is breaking the rule so
there's a norm for enforcing the norms
and that's a key way that these things
get work I get that totally I'm right in
saying that weapons were important part
of enforcing these norms as well right
because it meant that the strongest
person in the group wasn't necessarily
the one who had the most power anymore
yes so in a group of state chimpanzees
if there's a big chimpanzee going around
giving everybody orders and the rest of
you like want to take them down it's
kind of hard because you know only a
couple of you can really get close to
them and you could throw the first punch
when he wasn't looking but that's not
gonna help very much and so it's
actually pretty hard for any large group
to to actually counter the big guy but
in a group of humans with weapons you
could all stand kind of far away and
then 20 of you could stand far away and
I'll Pelt up with rocks
and that would be much more effective
job done and so human weapons and
language allowed social norm enforcement
much more than for other animals so
language is necessary in order to be
I'll say I have to tell you what this
other person did wrong hmm and then you
have to tell me that yeah that's you
agree that that was a rule violation and
then we have to talk about what to do
about it and all of those things are
just much harder to do with that
language I get that I've got a question
from George McGill who is one of our
listeners and he's a massive fan of the
book he asked a couple of questions that
I think are pertinent here and he asked
why do we gossip what percentage of
human conversation is gossip and does
Robin think people are aware of how much
they gossip gossip doesn't tend to have
a good reputation so people date to
downplay their tendency to gossip we
mostly discuss up when we talk about it
so a highbrow people or supposedly
gossiping less although that's not even
my extra notes no ever I've seen
highbrow people they're gossiping a lot
all the time no one ever talks about how
much they love watching TMZ today but
some people do so over time people are
more willing but but basically it's
striking how much people do guys have
given how much they seem to disapprove
of gossip but gossip is an obvious
useful thing for species like humans to
be doing first of all we just we need to
be talking about something because we're
just hanging out with each other trying
to show how much we like each other and
we're also trying to impress each other
and we're looking for something to talk
about that could be useful in gossip
this is pretty useful because gossip is
how we find out who's been doing what
and who we approve and disapprove of and
who we're gonna coordinate against and
so you know being such complicated
political creatures we're always trying
to form coalition's that have us on the
inside and our rivals on the outside and
gossip helps us do that so that's part
of unfortunate enforcing the rules and
norms right if I do something wrong and
sure a bunch of I know that there is
this external accountability that's
going to come back and get me because if
Susie sees me doing it she's gonna tell
Brian and Brian's gonna tell and did and
right it goes around right so when it's
working well that's when Susie's not a
lying [ __ ] Yeah right
but say we have this norm mechanism and
we aren't gonna use it fairly maybe you
and I are gonna try to use it to our
advantage against our rivals yeah well
we still need to use gossip to make that
work we have to decide what we're gonna
accuse somebody else of even if it's not
true yep and decide who else will go
along with us and then spread our false
rumor yep so that we can make our rival
suffer for this false rumor I mean once
we have this norm a constant loop can
use it for all sorts of purposes some of
them good some of them at but we'll
still need gossip for that I got at work
I got that so both in logical deduction
what how have you been able to make this
make these phenomenon more established
in history because we don't know what
was happening
5,000 years ago with a high degree of
accuracy in terms of social norms and
stuff like that so how have you actually
been able to when you wrote the book how
are you able to manifest this so the
fundamental issue here is that humans
around us all the time are doing all
sorts of strange things and when we ask
them why are they doing that they give
us some reasons and if we don't think
much about it then the reasons kind of
makes sense but the more we probe into
the details the less sense it makes so
that's this puzzle I collected over a
career of all these strange things
people are doing and so the fundamental
question is well what are people
actually doing and there's really no
escaping the following process which is
to generate alternative theories about
what they're really doing and compare
each of these alternative theories to
the many details of our behavior any
alternative theory surely would make
sense of some of the patterns out that's
why you made it up in the first place
yep but the real challenge is to explain
lots of little details of behavior the
more little details of behavior that can
be explained by any one theory with with
making few assumptions than the better
that theory sits yes and
that's the whole structure here of
course that's in a sense most of social
science really mm-hm and and most of
science all sorts of things which is
just you have to have alternative
theories you have to have a bunch of
details of data and then you match the
theories to the details and you see
which theories better matches the
details so to generate these theories it
helps to have some general idea of what
kind of theories you might be looking
for so having some idea of how humans
evolved and where humans came from in
the first place gives you some things to
be thinking about in terms of theories
but in the end the the most fundamental
thing that's going on is taking the the
strange patterns of behavior and asking
which theories can make sense of these
and so mostly what we're saying in the
book isn't focused on looking at our
distant ancestors it's focused on people
today and what they're doing and what
could possibly explain these things
people are doing
I should mention my book has a co-author
Kevin similar an excellent co-author and
we the two of us wrote this book
together yep I got that so it's it's
interesting that logical deduction
appears to have brought us to I mean
it's a pretty robust theory it seems
like it explains an awful lot so I mean
if it's if it's wrong it's very
surprisingly wrong right at least in my
at least in my view I don't get me get
away you've dedicated an entire book to
us I'm gonna presume you don't think
it's wrong either well I don't think
it's wrong but um I'm really struck by
the fact that we're making a big claim
which should surprise you in the sense
that not only are we claiming
something's different than you thought
we are it should surprise you that it's
even possible to do that today yeah that
is people have been studying humans for
thousands of years now humans have
always been very interesting to other
humans so we have a vast history of many
millions of people thinking carefully
about human behavior and then trying to
explain it so after all that time how
could it even be possible to tell you
some very surprising result not about
just some small corner of human behavior
but about a wide range of living
behavior is that right there should be
surprising to you so I'm really struck
by the fact that we are saying a big
thing we are
that a lot of your preconceptions are
not just a little wrong a lot wrong and
that it's possible to say such a thing
and think that you're roughly right we
should you should know everything
already right you should know well about
most people and ordinary human motives
for most ordinary things you would think
so yeah not only do we all live a long
life but we're all the time talking to
ourselves and other people about why
we're doing things so it should be
surprising that we could be that wrong
about so many things and then I also
think it's surprising that with this
book where we arguably claim that people
are that wrong and have some at least
some decent arguments in support there
are so many people who just yawn and
can't be bothered to be interested but
they don't find the topic very
interesting I don't think that I want to
go for a beer with those people well
that's most of the world though so well
most of the world most of the world
isn't getting an invite to the pub if
that's the case well maybe since most
intellectuals aren't very interested I
would think that most ordinary people if
you sat down to them at the bar and we
started talking about them they would be
kind of interested hmm so I think it's
striking that most of our professional
elections are less interested well that
seems that is well it's about what an
intellectual is therefore so which comes
down to motive so we talk as if there
are intellectuals are there to you know
figure things out for us you know we try
to figure these things out for ourselves
and then you know we only get so far
because we're just one person and then
we have a busy life and then we have
these specialists out there and they're
supposed to be figuring out more for us
and when they figure out more then they
tell us and that we could all learn from
that that that would be the simple
theory of what intellectuals are for
yeah it's wrong it's not a fact that
intellectual is a forum either there
which helps you explain why they are in
fact not telling you that many useful
things that often what are they there
for well some kind of intellectuals are
just kind of like why we are talking to
each other in ordinary conversation and
they're just an extension of the space
of word of conversation and then that
slips into intellectuals were there
just really really impressive and to be
high status people we all want to
associate with so in our ordinary
conversations a lot of what we're doing
is showing off we talk in our book as if
you have this mental backpack of tools
and when you have a conversation the
rule is the conversation is just
supposed to follow some random path on
whatever random topic it goes to you're
not supposed to try to control that very
much but wherever it goes you're
supposed to just show that you have
something interesting to say not
something very useful necessarily but
something interesting and if you can
just consistently pass that test all the
time then you're a pretty good Ally
you'd be a nice person have around
because wherever the conversation goes
whatever we need you've got stuff yep
and so that's a way we interact with
each other is mostly using conversation
as a way to show off as opposed to be
directly useful and then we are part of
these larger conversations in the news
media podcasts even academia and in
these larger conversations we are doing
something similarly we are being even
more impressive even more selective
about who to listen to and we want to
listen to people who are showing off an
even larger sharper hone mental backpack
of tools yep we're also staying in the
conversation whatever the current
conversation is in that scope with each
academic discipline as a conversation
news media has a conversation etc you
know the gossip around your office has a
conversation whatever it's on and you're
supposed to jump into that conversation
and show impressive things and that's
what most conversation even larger
intellectual conversations about is
mostly showing off so I'm an academic
and most academic journals they are very
selective about who they publish yeah
are they very careful and if you
submitted something to them most of them
were rejected if it's going to be
accepted they lots of suggestions bother
change it that would be very nitpicky
but mostly they're not actually
wondering how useful this is they're not
actually thinking very much about how
important this contribution will be and
whether it'll make the world a better
place they're mostly focused on how hard
was that is that a really difficult
thing and are we really impressed by the
fact that somebody could do that I I
recently did a podcast with Sabina
Hassan Felda who is author of a book
which talks about how beauty is leading
physics astray in eating
and I found it absolutely amazing -
first off I discovered that physicists -
people - which was a revelation a
revelation to me but secondly the
cognitive biases and the political power
games that get played with in the
physics community specifically we spoke
about that but obviously it'll it'll
expand out into many others but it was
whether or not your scene from the write
him sheet and and sort of kneeling in
front of the the correct sort of
powers-that-be and all that sort of
stuff it seems so strange for a layman
like myself to think that you presume
that science and academics are these
bastions of of knowledge purity do you
know I mean right now it's odd of course
that you would presume that if we just
said well you're a primate there you're
in a world of competitive primates who
try to get ahead from each other why
would you think there was this bastion
of purity out there where would that
come from how could it perpetuate itself
that's just pretty strange thing to
presume it is but we do presume that a
lot we do listen to these people who
give themselves pretty you know
high-minded descriptions and praise and
we just let them get away with it
politicians regulators CEOs scientists
you know musicians athletes all of these
people we let them give these pretty
high-minded grandiose pictures about
themselves and we accept it because what
we really want to do is just affiliate
with them because hey they're pretty
impressive if somebody knew that you hey
because you know you got to drop her
name I met her once many years ago
that's why I could drop her name but you
can drop any better cuz you saw you talk
to her more recently right yeah and she
is impressive and she's a sharp person
and she has you know important things to
say but honestly our main motivation
here is probably just to affiliate with
these impressive people and it doesn't
that much matter what they say I've got
I've got a whole bunch of other stuff
that I want to go into but I'm gonna
forget this question if I don't ask you
it now do you do you find yourself after
having done so much work in at this
particular field do you find yourself
second-guessing your actions every step
at the moment
uh no surprisingly I guess I saw and
still see our book as mainly focused on
the world and trying to understand the
world yeah it's not a self health book
or at least not intended to be a
self-help book er it's not intended to
be a voyage of self-discovery yep
it's intended to help you look out
around you and understand the world
yeah now of course you're part of the
world and so whatever it is you find out
about the world probably applies to you
but that's basically as far as I go
yeah yeah yeah mostly I say I assume
just I assume I'm like everybody else
whatever it is I find out about
everybody else I'm just gonna presume
I'm probably pretty much like that now I
might be different in some ways I
probably am but I'm not sure it's that
important how I'm different so I think
what's going on is that because we all
are supposed to pretend that we are
these high-minded people with these high
motives yeah then having to admit to
that seems like quite an admission of
failure in fact an admission sin of
sorts and then we feel like we should
repent and atone for our sin and find a
way to recover from our sinful nature so
that we can become these high-minded
creatures we've been claiming we are and
I just don't think that's gonna happen
it's just not really feasible to become
the high-minded creatures we say we are
we could certainly move a bit in that
direction and that well may be worth it
but the point of our book is just to
make you understand the basics about
everybody not so much just yourself I
totally get that I think it's it's nice
the distinction that you've drawn
between the analysis and commentary so
to speak that you guys have made in the
book and the prescriptive nature of how
you would get around it like the the ten
step it's not called the ten step
process to control the elephant in your
brain it's do you know I mean right well
first of all we have to decide whether
we like it or not I mean you know just
because we've been pretending to be
these angels doesn't mean it would
actually be a good idea if we tried to
become these angels we pretend we are we
have to think it through and so you know
first of all it's just it's not going to
be feasible to change us that much from
what we are we we have a lot of inertia
in what we are and we were built for who
we are and we can't really change
that much so the first order of business
is just to figure out what we are and
get oriented to that under the
assumption that probably won't be that
different from what it is by God then it
might be better to to our change
ourselves someone but probably the
biggest things is is just to be honest
with what we really are so like we say
you know there are these huge engines of
waste in our society where because we've
been pretending one thing and really
doing another thing we're wasting
enormous amounts of resources and maybe
we're gonna have to keep wasting a lot
of resources in those areas but we
should at least be aware of that and ask
ourselves could we waste a little less
resources there somehow and that may not
be via rising to our ideals it might be
through some other channel some other so
in general there's a conflict between
what you are and what you say you are
what you want to be there's you know
three fillies three possible strategies
one is to raise what you are up to the
ideals you pretend yep another is to
lower your standards down to where you
are yep third one is just like a plane
yep talk about something else right yeah
those are all live options here okay
well so I want to get back into some of
the meat and veggies or to speak of the
book itself I want to talk about
protects lying and cheating can you take
us through how you summarize that please
all right so there's this idea that we
have these norms others these rules that
are things you're not supposed to do and
then you're supposed to enforce the
norms and so what we're actually trying
to get away with not following the rules
because the rules are usually a bit in
our way and so you might think would be
hard to avoid these rules when everybody
else is watching out for deviations from
the rules and ready to enforce them but
it turns out not to be quite as hard as
you might think because what everybody
really wants to do is to look like
they're trying to enforce the rules
trying so hard to actually enforce the
rules as to avoid the accusation that
look you did not enforce the rule when
you were supposed to mm-hmm so we're all
really weakly motivated to enforce these
rules which
lets us get away with avoiding the rules
as long as we have any sort of weak
pretext just a little excuse
that's all everybody's looking for if
you're gonna be really obvious about
breaking the rules well they're gonna
have to come down on you because
otherwise they're gonna look bad but if
you give them any little excuse to
pretend that they didn't see it or that
it wasn't what they saw or whatever
they're just they're happy to have those
excuses because it's not like they
really care whether you follow the rule
themselves they just cared to look like
they were enforcing the rule when they
were supposed to I guess I can guess
that not only did the rules make lot of
people's lives more difficult but
enforcing the rules also make people's
lives matter something that's absolutely
a big pain so an example we give is the
example of drinking alcohol in public in
in many places most places in the United
States it's against the rules to drink
alcohol in public now and the police are
supposed to enforce that rule they don't
really want to they think they have more
important things to do I don't think it
they don't actually think it's that
harmful typically but they think that if
you really put it in their face waving a
big bottle of wine around say that
you're guzzling out of yeah then they
have to do something cuz you were you
were forcing them but they don't really
want to and so they'll take any little
excuse so a standard classic you know
solution is you put your alcohol bottle
in a paper bag and then you drink out of
the paper bag yes and now it's not
obvious what you're drinking out of now
it is kind of obvious in the sense that
whoever drinks out of anything whoever
drinks anything in public I'd have a
paper bag but alcohol you don't you
don't it's not doctor pepper into that
right right of course of course it's
alcohol but you've got this excuse as
the police have this excuse so the
police can look the other way and say
well it was a paper bag I couldn't tell
and that lets them pretend not to
enforce the role and we do this all the
time with all sorts of rules there's
this odd cooperation between the rule
breaker and the rule enforcer neither of
whom want to be at the mercy of the
rules and both of whom weirdly somehow
are working in like cahoots to actually
subvert them
yeah the rule enforcers just trying to
be lazy just trying to not deal with it
mm-hmm the rule breakers trying to help
the other guy to be lazy
okay the forest well mutually it's
mutually beneficial
right and this this happens all the
times and also there's there's kinds of
things you shouldn't say and if someone
says it too directly you know you'll
have to disapprove because if somebody
said hey this person said this thing and
you didn't disapprove you heard it then
now you're in trouble right yeah but as
long as I give you any decent excuse any
level of indirection say of hinting what
they were saying not saying it directly
a needle level of seeming to be joking
about it you know whatever it takes
then the people around you who would
have to enforce this rule they're
they're mostly quite happy to not
enforce the rule because you gave them
the excuse to pretend it didn't happen
which is why we can evade so many rules
which is why we put so much effort into
evading rules so so again so one of the
things that is the big thing that
happens in a lot of the areas in our
book that we talk about is bragging okay
so we're not supposed to brag you you
might notice that if you brag really
directly it's kind of frowned on people
like they're a bit embarrassed for you
yeah and they feel like have to be a bit
disapproving now as a matter of actual
fact people are bragging all the time I
mean you know in most conversations a
lot of what people say is bragging but
they're doing it somewhat indirectly
they are not directly bragging they
might just tell you how much fun their
vacation was this last weekend in Paris
and their stances I had so much fun I
just had to tell you about it yeah it's
implicit right and so we do a lot of
that sort of bragging and a lot of the
other things we do in life we are doing
for bragging so we go to school
phenomenally to brag but we don't like
to talk about like I'm better than you
cuz I went to a better school and you've
got a better degree so we have to
mention though I went to a school in
Boston's that sort of thing
yeah and similarly even medicine we tend
to think of medicine as something we do
for health but in fact or what we argue
in the book is that it's primarily
bragging you are bragging about how much
you care about people now that's one of
the most honorable praiseworthy kinds of
bragging we we have to brag about how
much you care about someone you love
yeah the last bragging and so we feel
like we need to be a little indirect
about it and so
we don't actually admit to other people
or even to ourselves so much about how
we push people to use medicine and use
medicine ourselves in order to brag that
we care about other people and a lot
other people brag that they care about
us I yeah I mean it's that virtue
signaling of look at how much I care is
a it's a pretty big flag isn't it it's a
pretty big flag to be waving and I mean
what's the what is our brains desired
outcome from this bragging social status
rising up a hierarchy appropriate mate
well for each thing we're bragging about
there could be a different purpose and
bragging is just like saying you're
better on some scale yeah and there are
different scales that matter in
different ways you know for some things
it's status of course status is flexible
and useful for many things but there's
also a more localized thing like you
might want to convince your spouse that
you are loyal to your spouse and that
you care about your spouse and that's
you know showing loyalty to a particular
person or your employer your your work
team I want to show your loyal to them
that you have their back that you care
about them those are kinds of bragging
loss about your ability and more about
your loyalties yeah ok ok so I want to
talk about some of the ways that hidden
motives manifest themselves quite
typically in modern life now you've got
a whole part of the book which is
dedicated to body language and laughter
conversations and a whole bunch of other
things consumer behavior and I want to
go through them because I want to give
people some some nice tacit the examples
of that can hopefully hit home some of
the concepts that we're talking about
here so body language was one of the
first one of the first things that
struck me having recently read a little
bit about it and I think you said
biologically an expensive act is that
right well it's expensive to fake okay
I'll said more precisely yeah so when we
use words it's often easier to say the
opposite what we mean because the cost
of using one set of words isn't directly
not that
the cost of using another set of words
but the body language tends to be
communicated in ways that are more
credible because it more naturally goes
along with what makes sense to do so for
example if you're stressed and scared
it'll show up in tension in your voice
because your body is tense because it
makes sense to be tense when you're
scared it makes less sense to be relaxed
when you should be scared because if
you're tense then you're gonna be ready
to move at a moment's notice and when
you relax you'll be sluggish and won't
move quite so fast yeah so the fact that
someone is relaxed is more of a credible
signal that they in fact are not scared
similarly you know talking with a big
booming voice is a credible signal that
you have a big booming voice cavity ie
you have a big body yeah but a lot of
energy to move air through it and that's
a credible signal that you are big and
that you have energy to spend yeah and
so again another credible signal you
know the fact that I look at you is a
credible sync signal that I'm interested
in you because well if I'm interested in
you it makes sense to look at you yeah
that's where I want to spend my
resources to looking at you because hey
that that's what I'm interested in so in
all of these ways and many more body
language tends to be more credible that
is the things it says are side effects
of choices we make because the signals
we're sending are truth yes and so it's
harder to lie about body language which
is something of a problem because we're
often in the mood to lie about any of
these things which is often why we deny
our body language and we downplay it and
so even though we're actually looking at
body language a lot and reading it a lot
and taking it seriously a lot we allow
each other to pretend that body language
doesn't matter so if somebody says words
that disagree with their body language
we're offering just willing to go along
with those words because hey we don't
want to fight him on it and so if that's
what they want to pretend to be thinking
or feeling then we'll let them do that
it's the easier route right oh and when
we're feeling somewhat cooperative at
least if it's a rival that we want to
take down then we might be happy to
point out the contradictions but
usually we are more cooperative mood and
so yeah body language tends to be more
faithful and therefore is more
problematic exactly when we are trying
to avoid admitting our motives I get
that laughter is a really odd phenomenon
isn't it it's a very bizarre thing is a
specially credible signal of being
relaxed so now smiles you might have
thought were a signal of being
comfortable and relaxed versus not but
we've learned to fake smiles and so
there are these forced faked versions of
smiles that to some eyes look like real
smiles and so you can't just use whether
somebody's smiling as an indication that
they're relaxed and comfortable but
laughter is a more credible signal so
laughter goes along with the concept of
play okay in humans and many other
animals we have play modes where in play
mode we switch into a mode where we are
going through the motions of doing real
things but not actually doing real
things and we get to practice lots of
real things in play mode and we only do
play mode when we're in a safe enough
environment that the real versions
wouldn't make sense and that we can all
feel comfortable enough to be exposed
enough to each other to go through the
play motions so so animals might play
fight or play chase but they do it in a
sort of way to make sure it's clear that
it's play versions but if when you're
playing sometimes you might like
actually hurt someone or they might
think they actually hurt someone at that
point animals and humans need a way to
say are we okay are we still playing or
or did we switch out a play mode because
somebody actually got hurt or thinks
they might get hurt or somebody decides
they they want to hurt somebody yeah um
and so laughter is that sort of signal
for humans it's a signal that we're
still playing and so humans are very
social and so a lot of our play is
social play that is we have all these
rules and in social play we play it
violating the rules which is if you
think about it a little you know
self-contradictory but say we're not
supposed to insult each other
yeah but we can play it insulting each
other now a play insult can be just as
insulting but you have to pretend it
wasn't serious and pretend you aren't
hurt so you have to go along with the
play insult and say that was just to
play insult haha and so if you're
pretending to be playing you have to
hide your hurt and keep pretending to
play at the insult yeah and so we use
play a lot to learn about social rules
and to explore social rules and to
explore the boundaries and even who's on
our side and who's willing to do what
about which real social rules just
because play lets us pretend
quote-unquote to violate rules so for
example say there's a rule about
something you and I can't say okay well
but you and I want to talk about it well
if we laugh and joke about talking about
it we might find out from each other the
other guy doesn't really mind if we talk
about it and then we could like just
actually start talking about it in
private and know that the other guy's
not going to tell on us because they
don't really mind so we can actually
figure out which rules anybody wants to
enforce and so it like this old saying I
guess Mel Brooks I think said you know
tragedy is when I hurt my little figner
finger laughs comedy is when you walk
into an open sewer and die which is that
a lot of humor is is about the
distinction between us not caring much
about things far away from us that don't
actually impact as much and so we use
laughter and often to probe those things
to figure out which rules and things
people care enough about that they would
enforce the rules and which they don't
it's like a safe space so to speak it's
supposed to be
I mean it's off actually but that's the
pretense you're when you're pretending
to play you're pretending to be in a
safe space and so unless you want to
you know acknowledge you're not really
safe you kind of have to keep going on
and pretending well everyone will know
the situation in which everyone's been
laughing and someone deems that they've
taken it too far and the laughter is
broken and the city the safe space is
now gone and you were very much back in
that real world with a
sense of guilt and a pang in your
stomach because you've said something
that's upset someone or you've right
watched someone say something that they
totally shouldn't have done and the
person on the other side of the rooms
face has just gone back to death stare
right and it's a hard choice to even
trigger that because say you know
somebody makes a joke and everybody's
laughing and now you are hurt but if you
admit you're hurt you take everybody out
of play mode and you kind of admit oh I
was weak enough that I had to take
everybody out of play mode because I
actually had hurt and you're trying to
show that you're strong and toughen and
it didn't bother you then you often like
pretend like it didn't hurt you so that
you can pretend that you're strong and
tough I guess that would be a modern
manifestation that kind of sucking it up
or keeping yourself quiet had that have
been fifty thousand years ago that would
be what you wanted to signal outwardly
you would want to signal that you were
tough enough to be able to take the play
because if you weren't that would
identify you as a weak you don't want to
be making the right strategy choice in
the right context so like if this is a
rival who's insulting you in yes play
mode you have a choice between
pretending that it's beneath you to even
respond because they're not really a
challenger to you and you don't really
care about anything they have to say or
on the other hand deciding that they've
made a provocation and you're going to
show that you don't take these things
lying down say you could pretend it's
really an insult about your friend and
out about you and then you could take
the stance of you're defending your
friend yeah okay so you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna make a fight out of
you're gonna make a conflict often like
we make a conflict out of something it's
a choice we can decide to ignore it to
let it slip by we can decide to make it
a conflict and we're supposed to be you
know evolution part of you deciding when
it's in our interest to do one versus
the other
exactly yeah you can in play mode you
can use it you can kind of downplay
whatever's occurring and use it as a
cushion or you can actually use it as an
excuse to magnify whatever's occurred
and escalate the issue depending on what
your preferred outcome is right you I
mean often what you might do is show
that you're so clever and strong by not
just letting it slide but by making like
a quip that's that jumps on that one
that turns it around on somebody them or
one of their allies yes and shows that
your
you're not hurt you're not hurt enough
that you or you have all your well worth
all to make such a clever retort yeah
yeah I totally get that that's all it's
it's interesting that laughter is so
it's so related to being relaxed and
that that signalling I mean everyone
will know the guy or girl who manages to
always get some what a very sexually
attractive partner because they're funny
especially in men that capacity to be
funny is one you know good sense of
humor is probably one of the the highest
virtues that girls would look for in a
potential mate and it's interesting that
that's so closely tied with being
relaxed which is a an indicator of
someone being at ease with in their
normal environment that they've got
worldly experience because they don't
often get ruffled by cetera et cetera so
it's a combination of social skill and
confidence and sort of innate likability
that can get everybody to laugh along
with you
so I mean an important thing to notice
is most laughing isn't about jokes so
it's not actually that you have a skill
at being funny I mean there is no such
thing it's at being funny there's the
skill of being relaxed and like showing
everybody in the group that you can play
well that you can read them well and you
know what you know they are
uncomfortable with are they're
comfortable with and you are confident
in the right at the right moments so you
know in general you know I people often
say that you know secret to success is
confidence and clearly it can't be that
easy evolutionarily confidence is just
like a knob you could turn out though
the problem is if you are overconfident
in situations that will justify it
people will often knock you down so
often confidence looks good when it goes
along with the skills that justify your
being confident yes in those skills it's
like if you don't do that that's when
you've got someone who's just fronting
right right right so like you can be
confident about your ability in a fist
fight
if you're not actually good in a
fistfight your confidence will get you
into fistfights where you lose and that
won't look very good and so really with
a really witty retorts etc other sorts
of social skills
I mean confidence is more the sign that
you have these other skills that you can
be confident in its carrying its
carrying the briefcase which has got the
nuclear football inside of it rather
than actually having to deploy the
football itself right right right I mean
you can if you can show people credibly
enough that you have various abilities
then they won't necessarily challenge
you to a full drag out fight they'll
they'll realize you probably have the
abilities you're coming claiming it's
not leveraging a trade it's just putting
a trade down in leveraging it's like
well look this is this is how much
equity I've got at ten times but you
only need to see you only need to see
that 10% of that you don't need to see
the full amount of my trade so I wanted
to talk about how consumer behavior is
influenced by hidden motives I thought
this was particularly interesting given
that I come from a marketing background
so I'm an economist and economists like
don't talk much about marketing and you
know implicitly we don't think much of
it or at least you know in their usual
mode but of court I'm of course I come
to realize the marketers know a lot
there's a lot of interesting knowledge
and body in what marketers know so when
we look at buying ordinary products the
usual story most of us will give if we
point to any one product is that there
are product features we like point to my
phone my car my sweater yeah you know
you will mention price reliability you
know fashion etc as the reason why you
bought that thing or even for an
experience you bought and we know that
that matters somewhat well we also all
kind of know that most people pay a lot
of attention to how the products they
buy and use make other people see them
they are looking for the image effect
the social effect on how people see them
when they buy news products and we all
kind of know that we all kind of know
that that's somewhat important but we
often still again don't admit it in the
context of each thing we do and we may
not be quite
aware enough to realize just how
important it is so when we think about
advertising for example we think
advertising is talking to us and trying
to trick us into things so for example
if we see a picture of a beer on a beach
we might think well they're trying to
trick me into thinking that this beer is
as good as a beach because it's sitting
next to a beach I mean house how stupid
would I have to be yeah I think that
just because you showed me a picture of
beer next to a beach and I like beaches
therefore I like idea yeah like your
particular beer right and so we often
think that advertising must be you know
just completely ineffective or it must
be effective on all these idiots out
there that we are not because we know
that merely because you show us a
picture of beer on a beach that doesn't
mean a beer is good unless we think like
all of us are stupid inside in our
subconscious and it doesn't matter what
our conscious mind thinks they're just
pushing our buttons and making us like
the beer even if we consciously don't
think we should yeah so that's you know
most people's simple theory of marketing
is that these things are really stupid
but I guess they work on somebody and
maybe they work on me unconsciously but
they shouldn't yeah because there's just
no argument there but we say well it's
actually a little more sophisticated
than that you are trying to project
yourself to people around you you were
trying to say a lot of things about
yourself and you say a lot of things
through the products you use so if
you're hanging around at a bar say
waving a beer people look at your beer
and they'll draw conclusions about you
from your beers and you're gonna ask
yourself well what beer do I want to
wave around so that people get the right
message about me that I want to send yep
and so all these products we haven't
used expand this vocabulary we have of
all the messages we could send kind of
sweater I wear they're kind of car I
Drive the kind of phone I have it all
says things about me and I care what
other people think about me and I can
say them indirectly through these
products in ways that's even deniable if
someone who accused me of trying to show
off something brag about various
features I all just claimed no no no I
just like these products features and so
the key idea here is that this language
of associations between
products and features of people is
created by these advertisers without
this picture of a beer on a beach people
wouldn't look at that beer and think
beach yes and now I want to wave the
beer round and now because of that ad
they think beach so I can say I'm a
beach guy by waving that beer and
together for many people what they want
to say that's the thing they want to say
about themselves is I'm a beach guy yeah
or whatever equivalent it is I I did a
podcast with social chain some of the
listeners will know and have listened to
it and during that so ayran Club nights
that's my job in the UK and during that
conversation I got on to the concept of
self branding that we do so every night
after our event has gone we'll have a
photographer there and he'll take photos
at the event and the next morning those
photos will get uploaded onto Facebook
and people go on and they'll tag
themselves and they'll tag their friends
and sometimes I'll save them and they'll
post them on their social media and
they'll have it on their Instagram and
all the rest of this stuff and the guys
from social chain were asking me about
how we compete in a marketplace which is
incredibly homogeneous when club nights
are people in a room getting drunk to
music and it really doesn't matter how
much more complicated you try and make
it I've done this job for 12 years but
it was people getting drunk in 2006 when
I started and it's people getting drunk
in a room to music now in 2018 and it's
not going to change so they asked how do
you compete because in a small city like
Newcastle with a hundred thousand people
there's a finite number of venues
there's maybe only 20 venues that have
got appropriate licensing conditions to
be able to actually operate events in
them so you mean that you could be in
the same venue as another competitor
with the same drinks prices with a
similar music policy etc etc and what I
started talking about was that we try
and compete a lot of the time on the
intangibles of the brand value and what
that says about the customers that go
there and this example that I like to
use is if I speak to someone and I ask
them so how was your night how was your
night last night you went out to X place
last night how was it the first thing
that they'll say is I'll make it was
unbelievable who so many fit girls there
and you go what hang on a second
the other consume
of the product have no bearing on the
actual product itself I don't ask you
how your new iPhone is and you say I am
a it's fantastic David Beckham's got one
you actually talk about the features of
the product but very specifically with
club nights what people do is they use
it as this signal to other people
because they're gonna get their photos
tagged there and it's all I go to voodoo
on a Saturday that means I've got these
particular kinds of traits that you can
infer from the fact that you've seen me
tagged in the photos and this that and
the other and what it means is that our
job now as Club promoters quite highly
is to purely create brands that make
people want to be associated with them
because if you have a brand that when
someone gets tagged in the phone in a
photo of your event they're desperately
untagging it because it makes them some
social leper we that that's that's right
that's the kryptonite right like you
don't want that you want it to be I want
to go there because I want to be seen
there because it speaks to my values it
is it tells other people in the most
casual way possible what sort of a
person I am and as long as you can make
the values of the night something which
is aspirational for the people who
you're trying to get to go there you end
up winning now I'm sure many of our
listeners right now are saying to
themselves well that's what your
customers really like but I but they
cringe at that yeah and partly what
they're cringing at is the explicitness
of it yeah
the you know explicitly endorsing the
idea that I went to an event just to
show off that I was at the event and
that I'm a good enough to be at that
event right most people do not want to
talk explicitly in those terms and they
want to have some other excuse to say
why they were there like I had to do
something my friend went you know it's
where I go it's where the drinks are
cheapest it's right right and of course
and so you and I know that in fact
they're not that comfortable with
talking about this but it is is in fact
what's going on but sometimes you know
just like for many people just even
going to a club thing by itself look so
shallow that they don't want to go to
clubs right it's a cute boy it's because
how can you admit you're they run out of
excuses you think Gluck come on you had
to be at this club because you know you
could have been somewhere else drinking
for a lot cheaper
had 50 cent now you had to go to the one
that was the most expensive to get into
right right and so there's this you know
interesting equilibria where the more
you know and the more you can see
socially the harder it is to do these
things that would make you popular
because the more transparently you are
doing them to people like you who can
see these things but of course most
people don't see these things I'm sure
that's certainly an age effect this
often teenagers and young people are
doing these things and from their point
of view they think they have plausible
deniability yes and any 50 year old
who's looking on going saying no you
don't see why you're doing this but
still among your peers you have
plausible deniability and that's what
counts I totally get that so moving on
to charity altruism and being charitable
seem like quite modern concepts we don't
one I personally don't think about
putting together a society's giving some
lonely outcast a portion of their recent
kill out of pity or whatever but there's
an established background for this sort
of phenomenon is that right yeah I think
you're just wrong about what
hunter-gatherers were like so in fact
foragers or hunter-gatherers were
extremely egalitarian okay they lived in
groups of say 20 to 50 and they had very
little physical property and they shared
most food and other things and they made
collective decisions and so they did
help each other a lot they raise
children together you know the whole
group would range children teach them
things like that and so in fact in the
typical forager hunter-gatherer group it
was a very high degree of sharing and
help if you were a weak member of that
group why would you be helped along by
the rest why would they want to share
resources with you well certainly if
you're temporarily weak they want to
show that they're loyal to you and each
other and that's how they help each
other and that they don't they are a
loyal member of the group and they're
showing anybody that they help you that
somebody else would be in that need
they'd help them too and if they are in
that needed at some point in the future
all right and so they'll and they'll be
as long as you seem to be trying as hard
as you can they may even have a fair bit
of tolerance for you not being quite as
productive as others certainly if you're
young you may not be pulling your weight
but later on you know they hope that you
eventually will get strong enough to
pull you weight good analogy yeah and
they have a fair bit of slack they have
a fair bit of extra resources usually
and then you know it's sometimes there's
times of famine etc but but usually
there's enough effort to resources that
they can carry a few slackers if as long
as those slackers don't you know look
like they're trying to slack if they're
only limping when you see them but the
running around here's something about
them running around totally fine when
you turn your backs turned so actually
most human workgroups all through
history have been like this I mean we
can look at you know literature on
people in a in a factory shop or things
like that and often that the people just
form the strong norm of what we together
are gonna help each other and support
each other and we don't want to let
management say take us apart by figuring
out which one of us are more productive
and you know we're making us all work
harder and so there was a whole era when
management was trying hard to
incentivize factory workers to work
harder and to work better in them and
the factory workers would be
coordinating to stop them because they
were trying more to protect this one one
for all and all for one sort of work
group where they they just took care of
each other is that unionizing a unions
would be a way to express that more
formally but it happened formally a lot
that so this so humans really have this
ancient egalitarian streak and we do
that within families certainly we often
you know take care of other people and
families even if there are a bit of
slackers if they are not slacking too
much yeah
so you've mentioned a couple of times
that typical sort of hunter-gatherers
nomadic roaming bands of humans were
groups of 20 to 50 I had it in my head
before reading your book that it was
groups of 250 and that there was a
perceived psychological limit on the
number of close connections that we can
hold is that do you know if that's got
any is that got any truth pass on it so
that the there's two different units one
is the unit of the group that like
sleeps together every night and then
every few months gets up and moves
together to a new campsite okay so that
group side is the band of 2250 yep now
these bands periodically would meet up
with other bands and those other bands
would be of a similar size and so they
would know enough of these other bands
that roughly they would know uh roughly
150 people total okay so these groups
would typically have good relations in
fact if you you know were born in one
group you'd leave to another group if
you were say a woman and at the age of
maturity and so they wanted to keep good
relations with the other groups because
that's where they get their future mates
and so mostly these groups had good
relations and mostly they met up
periodically and so that's the larger
group of honoured 50 was all the people
you'd ever met in your life was probably
like 150 people okay and there's a I am
right in saying that there's a proposed
upper limit on the way that you can map
social interactions right and it's about
that Dunbar's number by robin named
after Robin dead Marv is this named for
the hundred and fifty which is roughly
we seem to have cognitive capacity to
think about 150 people and a fair bit of
detail and and know quite a lot about
them and if you have larger groups than
that then you have to back off on how
much you know about these people and you
your ability to interact with them gets
weaker I get that I was reading sapiens
by Yuval no Harare and he was talking
about how our brains are
disproportionately wired to be capable
of remembering plants seasons and
terrain navigation and I thought that
was really hilarious because everyone's
got that friend who claims to be
completely terrible with directions and
they'll get lost going home on a route
that they take they take every week but
he was saying that it is such a
fundamental skill that humans would need
to know that these berries under this
tree at this time of the year are fine
but a similar-looking berry that's next
to this particular kind of bush is
actually poisonous and that our ability
to map that sort of stuff is is super
interesting and super useful but then
when you look at modern-day society now
almost all of that stuff's been
outsourced we've got GPS
we don't need forage for food
we outsource the the quality control of
whatever it is that we eat etc etc I
thought that was really interesting yes
I mean the most amazing thing about
humans is how we have generalized from
our original environments we are so
culturally plastic that we are able to
adopt new norms and new social rules and
new situations and our brains that were
designed for these very specific ancient
tasks of you know navigating and finding
berries and you know reading each
other's faces etc mm-hmm can function
okay and usefully in this very different
world we live in that's an amazing fact
about our brains and and our mind design
is that there is enough generality there
to work in these very different
environments incredibly adaptable yeah I
think it's it would you would you say
it's accurate to say that our brains are
severely lagging behind the progress of
our environment well a creature who had
been evolved for this particular
environment where and now would just be
vastly better at us we are in this
environment yeah in that sense we're
lagging behind but we're still
functioning okay because there aren't
any such creatures that we compete with
that's a really vents so the amazing
thing is that we we can function and
make this society work even though we're
not optimized for this environment but
we can work well enough to make it all
work but still top of the tree right
yeah and and and growing yeah very true
so you touched on this earlier on about
whether or not you you weren't even sure
about whether it was desirable for
humans to remove these hidden motives
could you envision a world in which
we've dispensed with this the the
artifacts of our our heritage so to
speak and where we're completely free
from that the hidden motives that we
have in our brain I can imagine a lot of
things so I could imagine creatures who
did not hide their motives but we aren't
those creatures and we would have to
change a lot to become those creatures a
lot
so I'm not seeing that scenario play out
anytime soon I do see that sometimes the
world changes and we have to admit some
things that are unpleasant to admit and
then we often find ways to say create
some specialists who admit it among
themselves but let the rest of us ignore
it
yeah and so we often find ways to adapt
socially so that we can have a similar
attitude about things even if somebody
somewhere has to be realistic about
things I get that um can you explain
your idea of the press secretary please
I thought this was super interesting so
that's not original with us it's you
know many people have mentioned this but
I think it that helps you see yourself
in a different way
yes so we often realize we have this
vast mind underneath us and we are
sitting on the top of it we think as if
we were the king or president running
over all these minions underneath us and
instead this metaphor of the press
secretary says well think of yourself as
the press secretary instead yeah you're
there near the top you you hear people
at the top saying things but you're not
actually making the big decisions your
job is just to see the big decisions
being made and make up some excuses for
them
your job is to justify somehow to the
press who then says what were you doing
there's a Stephen Kass quote here that
says you are not the king of your brain
you are the creepy guy standing next to
the king going a most judicious choice
right that's an excellent if if somewhat
disturbing image as we do like to think
of ourselves as running ourselves and
it's hard not to think that way
sometimes but where's the sense in which
we don't run ourselves nearly as much as
we think we do yeah I totally get that
understanding our brains in this way is
is it helping people liberate them I'm
aware that the the point of this book is
not to be prescriptive and I think
having one exposed to a lot of the
self-development and sort of self
learning introspective work world over
the last couple of years it's really
refreshing actually to hear a book which
just posits an idea that appears to be
pretty pretty well-founded
and doesn't try to be too prescriptive
about it but if you were to make a not a
prescription but if you were to draw a
conclusion that gives people a little
bit of a sense of direction to move
forward have you got one well the people
who most need our book are the people
who job it is to describe and understand
our world say social scientists and
policy analysts they are constantly you
know describing our world in enough
detail that they use that as the basis
for some policy reforms that they
propose changes to our world on the
basis of their story about what our
world is so if those people's stories
are just wrong that's just gonna go
badly it's a loop a vicious echo chamber
of bad upon bad right well again if
people say think that education is to
learn more material and then they
propose policy reforms on the basis of
helping people learn more material
faster if in fact school isn't about
learning material then people will just
not be interested in those policy
reforms they will ignore them shrug
their shoulders and go on with what
they're doing which is basically we've
seen for the last several decades policy
researchers have come up with lots of
ways we can learn more material faster
and mostly we just have not adopted
those things which is a problem from the
part of you of all those people's work
an effort trying to reform education I
understand I understand completely so it
is it is interesting seeing just how far
off the mark
our minds are our modern minds are when
we compare them with exactly what's
going on I think we definitely probably
give ourselves far too much credit for
her for what it is that we understand
about why we do the things that we do
and then on top of that as well because
of the very specific kind of social
structure that humans have evolved from
we apply even more of this unfair
unwarranted justification and hope I
suppose to a degree in faith to the
people in these positions of power like
we were talking about academics earlier
on and politicians and policymakers and
people like that and it is a
there's a lot of masks that are being
worn including the one that we're all
wearing ourselves right right so a
standard story we moderns tell about
ourselves is that the ancients just they
were in a world and they just did what
tradition told them to do and they
didn't really understand their world
they didn't understand why they did it
or why they should do what they were
doing but they just kept doing what they
were supposed to be doing and that kind
of worked and today we are much more
consciously aware and understand our
world we understand the nations were in
and the companies were in the families
were in and our technologies etc and so
that we can reason more consciously
about these worlds to make ourselves
improve ourselves and make our world
better and there's a sense in which
that's true to some degree it's just a
lot less true than we like to think
because we actually understand our world
a lot less and we think I mean we have
stories about each of these things and
there are plausible stories and they're
the stories we've been telling ourselves
but we haven't noticed as well as we
should that they just don't fit the
details very well and this is one of the
reasons why many of our larger scale
plans just go awry it turns out to be a
consistent phenomena that when people
make big plans make social reforms big
projects for companies and Nations etc
these big projects and plans just go
badly a lot and we scratch our heads and
wonder well well we had a good argument
we had a good story it all made sense
what why did it go so badly and part of
the reasons is we are just haven't come
to terms with the fact that we are not
understanding our world and ourselves
nearly as much as we like to think
something so maybe could if we tried
harder and looked at the hidden motives
the elephant our brains but that's hard
to do totally I totally get that
so robbing of absolutely love today
thank you very much for coming on can
you tell the listeners at home where
they can find you online
well our book has a website elephant in
the brain calm I have a separate website
on myself Hansen that G mu GD you laugh
you search for my name or my co-authors
name you can find lot more stuff about
us we're on Twitter or on Facebook etc
overcoming bias as well very briefly
all right that's a blog I've had for 10
years now fantastic I mean everyone
everyone needs to go and check it out
I've been it's been RSS tup and I'm
reading through stuff as quickly as I
can there's some really really cool
concepts on there well Robin I really
appreciate your time the link to
elephant in the brain and all of your
socials and blogs will be in the show
notes below thank you very much it's
been great chatting Cheers thank you
[Music]